instead of going to a funeral home after
you die you can go there to die think of
the convenience watch so this is the
room where you have the Medical Aid and
dying yes this is this is where it uh it
happens people who are approved for
medical assistance and dying can come
here with their doctor and loved ones to
end their lives at a cost of at least
seven hundred dollars it's a lot of
organization uh
on on our part to really make it a
respectful and uh meaningful event for
the for that family it's what Michelle
Brunell recently opted for his family
says he had emphysema and his quality of
life had deteriorated but he didn't want
to die at home or in the hospital
suicide rooms in funeral homes this is
real this is actually happening right
now